à bobigny se dérouler cette semaine une
curieuse expérience d'hypnose collective
un magicien jean lui dexter se proposait
d'endormir plusieurs personnes pendant
huit jours imaginez la surprise et la
joie des contribuables de bobigny lorsqu
ils s'aperçurent en pleine période de
déclaration que parmi les volontaires
hypnotisé se trouvaient leur contrôleur
des impôts
[Musique]
a surpris parce que vous avez reconnu
parmi les dormeurs un contrôleur du
trésor de bobigny malheureusement
mercredi matin à la stupeur générale le
contrôleur du trésor se réveille c'est
une catastrophe
on aurait bien voulu qu'ils dorment
davantage riz jusqu'au 10 au moins pour
gagner environ 7 jours
on va faire une tentative à la demande
pressante d'aller contribuables
balbyniens nous avons donc tenté de
rendormir ce contrôleur du trésor
original nos par avance recueilli sa
déclaration
alors monsieur vous êtes livrés à cette
expérience
oui j'ai participé depuis samedi
vous avez dormi combien de temps je
pense je environ une soixantaine
d'heures qu'est ce que vous faites comme
métier
je suis fonctionnaire je travaille dans
les services d'administration du trésor
êtes au 13 heures est-ce que vous pensez
que vous pourriez vous rendormir
m'endormir possible je suis un peu
essayé je veux bien que vous tendre sur
l'expérience
détendez vous
laissez les libyens quelqu'un faisait
regarder fixement les y attend ces
mamans ne pense à rien d'autre parce que
je vous dis rapidement je vais passer
derrière vous conseille fortement me
regarde ce titre ça va aller très vite
avec j'en suis persuadé les yeux déjà il
reste encore fallait-il être sûr qu'il
ne s'agissait point d'une supercherie
pour avoir la certitude qu un percepteur
d'or il n'existe qu'un moyen mais un
moyen infaillible
celui-là d'or bel et bien hélas pour les
conflits berdugo bini les autres
inspecteurs des impôts de la région sont
peut-être moins durs de la feuille
tout le monde ne peut être sourd comme
un pot
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]